M it's
God it's
God deun steon which one Jesus Is God
yeah how would you debunk it that's
changing it you're try you're trying to
change the subject I'm trying to
understand what the brother's talking
about he just had this question he just
had this question one question how would
you are you a Muslim I'm not Muslim I'm
I'm strictly monotheist I'm a you're a
monotheist yeah I'm I'm I'm unaffiliated
I don't go to church when I look at that
I just there's no way did what what
makes what what's what's wrong with this
because Jesus Christ was a commun being
even in the even in the Bible I don't
want to bring the Bible into you want to
bring the Bible I don't want to bring it
into it Bible says God is one God is one
and so Jesus says go out and baptize in
the name of the father Son and the Holy
Spirit but you can't you can't you
can't no you can't that's the reason I
don't want to bring it into it why
because you said even in the Bible so
I'm showing you in the Bible he's God
yeah but is that the problem is that God
in the Old Testament is one and then
tell the New Testament it becomes a
trinity what happened in the Old
Testament it's a trinity it was one God
it says the Trinity is what is the
Trinity bro no there is no there is just
one Define the Trinity for me cuz you
keep saying one God versus like what is
the Trinity you say that the Trinity is
Jesus Christ God and the Holy Spirit
what about them but for me no what about
them what about them you you cannot
worship all three you have to worship
God only my brother you're not telling
me you're not relax let's slow down okay
you're not telling me what the Trinity
is so what is the Trinity I don't
believe in it I know like for example I
don't believe in t you airm T right and
from what you
T so I don't believe in is basically
what there's one oness is the uniqueness
and oness of God right so I don't I
don't I don't affirm Ted but that
doesn't mean I can't tell you what it is
you know what I'm saying so when you say
trinity what is the Trinity any any any
anything that you add to God like
whether it's uh other uh whether it's
other partners or other beings other
gods you can't be worshiping other gods
it has to be the one true Mighty God
creator only so you don't know what the
Trinity is that's what I'm hearing
whether it's a no no whether it's a
duality a trinity or quadral or whatever
you're still not telling me what the the
Trinity for us is going to be the same
so what the Trinity is is is Prophet Isa
Jesus God and uh Gabriel the Holy Spirit
the holy spirit so these are the three
these are the three the Holy Spirit of
Christianity yeah but me you ask me how
I can debunk this yeah how would you
debunk in Islam is simple so in Islam
brother let him speak he doesn't know
yes he doesn't know but let him he needs
to say that no no no it's fine but he's
trying to say that it doesn't make sense
that's what he's trying but how can he
say something doesn't make sense when he
doesn't know what it is you know what
I'm saying arguing your point he's
arguing fact that Jesus is God does not
make sense but he brought the aru he's
not trying to prove you wrong no he's
not he's trying to understand try to get
out understand and you're not brought he
brought up the Trinity let's try when no
look let me just I'm going let you go
but these guys don't know what's even
happening he said that the Trinity is
not even in the Bible so when I ask him
wait what is the Trinity and he can't
tell me what it is how can he tell me
that the the Trinity is not in the Bible
maybe he doesn't know and that's and
that's exactly fine that's fine what if
he doesn't want to admit it okay sure
that's fine if he doesn't want to fine
doc he's asking you a question just
based off of a false premise though he
is not trying to prove you wrong he is
trying to ask it's about proving if he's
trying to understand then if if he's
trying to understand then he should say
hey man I actually don't know what the
Trinity is can you tell me and I can
tell him what the Trinity is and show
them how it's in the Bible don't just
say something you don't know but he's
trying to understand
how I never said anything say because
when I told no no it's not that you
didn't know you have knowledge you have
knowledge but when I told you that it's
an interpretation and it's not a
translation and you can look this up on
your own time and I can come back later
it's initation you said no yeah I said
that some of it I said that some of it
is an
most of a translation no there is no you
can't translate so you can't translate
Arabic you cannot translate the words of
God in that context ask me what says who
ask me why exact very simple you're
assuming that it's the words of God that
can't be translated no no no that's not
what it's not Haram to be translated
that's what I'm trying to say you
interpret I didn't say Haram you're
saying it's in you don't have the
ability to translate because most of the
Arabic if I said something from you to
you for example in Arabic it's not the
same structure Integrity as in English
so when you're having it so what we say
is it's not translated it's interpreted
even in the official interpretation
that's what it said it's official
interpretation not a translation okay so
for example you said cool the first
verse of Surah um about him being recite
the first one all right and in the
translation it says say Allah is one is
that a translation or interpretation no
it isn't an
interpretation it is is that is that is
that how the words translate in English
uh it there it's missing a few words
actually what what words is it missing
so how many
say Allah he's the
one what is what is one keep going back
to book see even without the Bible or
the quran's have a
conversation so you're right and wrong
ask me how ask me
how see this what I said look no ask me
but this is what I said I said aric
that's why aric is different you see I
said that the Quran is both a
translation and an interpretation that's
my whole point if if it's not no that's
my whole point if it's an part of is an
interpretation you can't say it's it's
part of it's translation I agree then
it's then it's interpreted in English
something yeah but you can't say quarter
translation and three4 interpretation
that's not how it works no no bro come
on literature wise if we go to
literature listens if I interpret let's
get to the C so the whole point is this
is inter cor what's on your shirt he
asked a question so these are this is
the Trinity if you ask me how to debunk
this for us it's very simple so for
Islam we believe in all you also believe
in Judaism your believe in Moses mhm
right perfect we believe in all the
prophets that came before woo so the
question would be good the question
would be in the sense why is it no I'm
just I'm I'm just so the question would
be in the talmud in the Jewish scripture
T that's not that's that's uh that's the
scripture of Moses no no no no that's
the that's rabic that's rabic text
that's rabic text from the stones of
Moses no it's not it is from the of so
they say that you're confusing the Torah
and the tal the is the explanation of
the so you talking about if we combine
them together the Cornerstone of the
Jewish faith the in the Torah okay does
it say the Trinity and the Torah does
and the Torah say so so how does it say
when there has not been a son yet that's
one of the questions that in the Torah
in the Torah it talks about the Son of
God what are you talking
about where does it say when the son
hasn't even existed yet he has existed
that's the point the Trinity is that the
father Son and Holy Spirit share the
same divine nature as God meaning
they've always existed together sharing
the same Divine Essence so the sun has
always been makes sense sure it's always
been then the next question would be why
then bring M into the equation why not
just bring the Son of God into it so if
you're
bringing what happened yeah just to
complete the question what happened what
is the cut of point where you said the
Son of God needs to enter the equation
because apparently what happened is not
working why why are the sorry man
myran's playing it's time to pray
brother how would you how would
you a long time ago I know yes but so
how do I prove you ask me how to so you
ask you ask why why why not start off
with the sun and why why is bringing
Moses I'm asking yeah that's one the
question is Abraham is not the son
Abraham is a prophet yeah Abraham is a
prophet right yeah he's a prophet Moses
is a
prophet why why not just skip Moses well
because there's a time that God does
everything so the the time that God does
the the purpose of the son is to come
redeem mankind of their sins Moses and
the rest of the prophets are to prepare
the world for the atoning of the Sun so
they foreshadowing they're pointing to
the sun he's going to come he's going to
redeem us where these sacrifices are all
pointing to the Sun and his ultimate
sacrifice so they all are foreshadowing
his coming but see that's so anyway
that's the fallacy that we also go to
between Muslims and Christians Why will
why will he need to
die you to for your forgiveness for your
mercy as Christians are you asking me
yeah I'm asking you oh yeah your
understanding of it yeah yeah so so
according to the Torah um it says that
blood is the thing that makes atonement
for your sins so that's why they were
sacrificing lambs and goats and oxes to
God right to cup to atone for them but
it was
only it was only temporary like they
they had to keep doing it so the Son of
God we so we needed a a representation
of mankind for our sins to have a
complete atonement so the Son of God
came represented mankind took on flesh
and he gave his life as the atoning
sacrifice to cover us forever which is
which this is one of the cors of
Christianity yes I it right in in Islam
it's different but why not because
because that's just the word of man the
both those both those books are written
by man man you better get them you
talking about the Quran now there's no
no there's no way around that both of
them are written by man you want to
believe that both of them are written by
man let's let's both get them let's get
them the way I see it is before muham
before Jesus and before those books man
if you look at the reality you just
first of all the Quran came through the
honorable Muhammad okay but the the
Bible came through the honorable but
even before that humans existed for a
very long time like thousands of years
right before before those two books even
came into uh creation right into
existence so just by looking at reality
you see a creation right that's
automatic logic follows that there's a
Creator so there's so just based on that
even without those books I can say well
there's one there there has to be a the
Bible says that and even the Quran says
that too okay but like even without them
right the reality is telling me that
because there's a creation there yeah
but now the question is just who is that
who is the creator the one true Mighty
God creat how do you know who that is
because the the reality you know the
logic is is you see the cre if you see
the creation then there's obviously a
Creator yeah but but how do you know who
that is now who that is yeah that's the
question well who or you can you could
give him any names you can give him any
uh titles right but he no he has to
reveal himself to you for you to know
him right see but that's all now just
word of man you see that's it's not the
word of man it's the word of God that he
gives through man okay but you're still
the one that's saying that is that I'm
trying I'm trying to look at it purely
from okay let's be objective okay so for
example there will be things that we can
see that you know not any man could just
make up like for example prophecy right
and this is where we your monotheist God
would be able to predict something in
the future exactly how it happens and
that shows that he's CU he's all
powerful exactly they don't know so that
will show that's what we call the
fingerprint of God like you know that's
his identity that's how we can identify
who God is yeah but then the word of man
can use and manipulate those type of
things to try to spin it into something
that might not be true okay so let's do
this for example do we have a Bible we
do have a Bible go to Isaiah 53 for me
I'm going to just read like a couple
passages for you and you tell me I want
to take a pause I'm sorry I want to take
a pause just to let him know because we
can't stay here forever but yeah I'll
just tell him from our context point of
view you don't need okay you don't
believe in these These are the word of
man right ring by man so your question
but I just want to know because we
reached here so I want to understand
what your question was your question was
in terms of what basically who it is who
it is no you said you me to deunk this
I'm strictly my theist my question is
can you debunk that because they our
whole thing is yes our whole thing is we
don't need that their reasoning behind
there being a son so you don't believe
that no we do not Jesus I don't believe
that either but the whole point is it's
a simple because I don't believe we need
a conduit so that's kind of but you but
the Quran says Muhammad's your conduit
no that's no Muhammad is a Prophet but
he's your conduit too he doesn't no no
he doesn't need to atone for us anything
that I want I go to God but that's not
true even brother this is this is the
this is these are the cornerstones okay
I'm about to show you something I know
you're saying it's a Cornerstone I'm
about to show you that I'm your conduit
like on Judgment Day God's going Allah
is going to replace me with you to save
you from Hellfire how how's it going tol
me with you I'll show you I'll show you
look we go to and let me guess word of
man yeah word of man now this is word of
man right here no what are you talking
about how Prophet Muhammad is going to
ask for God's forgiveness
is that you are no I'm saying the
Muhammad teaches that Jews and
Christians will be your salvation from
Hellfire that we're going to suffer in
your place where your conduit that
sense show me that's not how it works so
inside Muslim about to go to uh me
see so wait I need to get something do
you believe in theith or not brother cuz
you confuse me right I don't I don't
believe in Quran or Hadith but I just go
you're trying to you're trying to trying
sure sure you know but you didn't go
with my authority when I told you it's
that you said no I was showing you I was
showing you the inconsistency of that
not you know I understand that but we
agreed if it's inconsistent you're not
using using it guys it's it's not an
authority on me it's an authority on him
I'm just showing the inconsistency with
that but on my explanation as since it's
my authority you s you rejected it you
said no just cuz it's your Authority
don't mean you're right about it that's
my whole point but this is this going to
be a kind of mouse then we're going to
continue this for longer okay so s
27678 okay no muslim wait wait we got to
read it in English Okay so it says when
it will be the day of Resurrection Allah
would deliver to every Muslim Jew or a
Christian and say this is your rescue
from Hell father now in the Arabic the
word rescue there is Ransom right so
yeah say again I'm sorry the word rescue
we your Ransom from Hellfire
right we're the ones no no this is not a
ransom what is it kak means your Escape
okay yeah it's it's
not all right so you're supposed to go
to Hellfire but your Escape your rescue
is us so yeah so I'm I'm going to tell
you um this is a very important thing
I'm not sure about this Hadith I I
didn't generally just hear of it before
but I will talk about the Islamic system
if you talk about the day of judgment
but this is part of it no no this is
part of it and if it's Muslim it's right
yeah by the way I'm not I'm not a half
you know what I mean so I'm not
everything
if you're talking about replacing Jewish
and Christians
with that's not what that's generally
not the thing that we're taught I know
that's not the thing we're taught so I
don't know that's my whole point that's
no no that's the thing so when you're
talking about being taught about
something talk about the Quran and the
Hadith throughout the cornerstones No No
this this is what I'm saying and when
you say you're not taught about this I'm
saying that the imams and the shakes
they're not going to teach you this no
no no no this is no they do so you you
miss you on Su so what I meant is is I
personally didn't hear of that Hadith
personally yeah I wasn't knowledgeable
so I'm not going to speak of it but I'm
going to try to explain the Islamic
system of the the day of judgment okay
with but you have you have to include
this in there now I cannot I cannot
discuss this without actually reading in
it okay so so this is my thing you can't
you can't I get what you're saying so
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm saying I
have to read about it before coming and
which is fair but what I'm say what I'm
saying is is that you can't describe the
Islamic system of Judgment Day or
Redemption without this without theith
of course absolutely 100% but I can
easily describe again in the Quran and
in the hadiths the ones that are very
famous we can easily say there's a
structure to what is so dear judgment
you a Muslim you're a sinner say you're
a sin I'm telling you we know what Jud
we know what Judgment Day is man but do
you know how it is for Islam we we we
know that you rely on the mercy of Allah
we we know that he admits who he will
and he forgives who he will on what
basis based on it's what you do
and in based on his Mercy what I do and
based on what his Merc his mercy so this
so in this context if I'm again I don't
know about thisi I have to read this has
nothing to do with this with with you
yeah this this has nothing to do with it
so I need I can I have to read about it
me and him we're your saviors yeah we're
your conduit if we say you're the
conduit no no if you say if you talk do
do you still have a problem with an idea
of a conduit absolutely so then you'll
have to you have because this is not
conduit you didn't save me we didn't
sacrifice you to save me you would have
to reject my S no no if i s if i s Quran
wise if I sined and I'm a Muslim I'll go
to hell no you won't you will no you
won't I will I could get it when the day
of Resurrection Allah will deliver to
every Muslim so this is I think je or a
Christian so I'll tell you the context
of readingi again I haven't read it so
again every has a context I don't know
the context of this one that's why I
have to read you know what it actually
there's there's another one that gives
more detail no no but what's the context
of this Hadith it's Judgment Day that's
the context no so usually when Hadith
happens is let me let's let's play this
out Prophet so what happened with 1 2 3
in this exact situation what's going to
happen so the prophet then replies we
have theith so what's the context of
this that's not every situ that's not
every Hadith no that's actually that's
actually every situation so they would
say actually every Hadith does not come
from a question being asked to Muhammad
and it comes from no it comes from a
topic being brought up the topic is the
day of Resurrection why would I just say
oh this person is a cond there has to be
an explanation look so but I will tell
you are are you here every day
are you every day or you know Sundays
Sundays only yeah next Sunday how about
I read about it and tell you I
come that's point I'm tell go to live
okay AB so so that's one of the things
I'm telling you about me as a Muslim I
feel comfortable enough I feel safe
enough and secure enough to be like
listen brother which is what I love
about you I'm not halfers I need to read
about it and come back to you you asking
if I believe in the 100% but the whole
conduit question the whole conduit
question that's a conduit no no the
whole point is can you speak why can I
not ask God for forgiveness directly you
don't you don't look again you can ask
God for forgiveness uh directly and why
do I need why do I need someone to be
sacrificed that's a good question why
does a Jew and a Christian need to be
sacrificed for the Muslim Allah so I
don't that's the whole point I can't
speak for thisi if I understand if I
understand it next week and you're here
I'll suddenly visit you okay so at this
point I got you so at this point this is
what I'm saying the only reason why I
brought this up is
because you're arguing about the exactly
so I was I was just showing I was just
showing how the how it backfires like if
you have a problem look I have a problem
if you have a problem with Jesus person
with a step Stone between me and God so
this is what it is no no no this is not
what it is so for example how is this
not a Jew or a Christian being your
stepstone between you and God because
it's very simple do I need if I'm
someone right now I didn't sin why would
I need someone in Christian Su you s all
of you guys S no no no we all sin but I
was that's why I asked you about the
system of Islam so if your sins are more
than your good deeds are more than your
good deeds you go to H if the opposite
you go to so if I already on how it
works that's based on Allah mercy no no
no that's the thing he said you are
going to have Deeds good deeds and sins
even if you have good deeds you can go
to hell no no no so that's the thing you
are going to you're going to J do you
want me to show you that too you can
have good deeds and if your good deeds
overpower your bad Deeds then guys if
the balance if the balance is tipped no
no they say even with the balance is
tipped do you want me can I show you
what I'm saying I know what you're
talking about what am I talking what am
I talking about it says it says in in
conjunction it's going to be like no
matter how many Good Deeds you do you're
not going to enter God's heaven unless
God's mercy without without his Mercy CU
all your it goes even beyond that I'm
going to let you finish but I'm going to
show you that it's not even that it's
even that I'll tell you I'll even go
beyond that that even if you have
billions of billions of good deeds in
your life brother it doesn't even come
to the to the gifts of eyesight that God
gives you so you are going in with God's
mercy we're going in with God's mess but
we don't need someone to be sacrificed
in context regarding the you I just
showed you that you need somebody to be
I'm telling you regarding the Hadith I
will absolutely did you did you hear the
cuz I want to make sure you're caught
out okay so you heard that a Jew and a
Christian get substituted for a Muslim
in Hellfire right okay so that's a can I
read the yeah um wait I I was about to
show you the other thing but I know what
speaking about so that's what I'm
telling you I know it so no you don't
you didn't know I was about to bring up
bro you're talking about yes I'm not
talking about Allah's Mercy then what
you said you were going to talk about
Allah's mercy no so what I was going to
show you was is that it's not even
that's not even what determines your
salvation or you going to heaven or hell
the Hadith talks about how Allah created
some for heaven and he created others
for hell and that's what and he also
said in
the we created you we already knew what
some of you are going to do but it's not
just about knowing he he created you for
this yeah that's what he said and then
he gave you the freedom of choice you
don't have a freedom of choice if he
created you for hell no he said he
already knows what you're going to do
dude there's a difference not even let
me talk there's a difference between
having for knowledge right God's all
knowing so he knows the end before it
happens exactly I'm we're not talking
about for knowledge we're talking about
actively um making something happen so
if I know that you're going to go to
hell based off your actions then boom
that it is what it is but created you no
if I if I create you for Hellfire that's
me purposely creating you for the
destination of Hellfire that's
transation Lost in Translation that's
the whole point we're trying to explain
to you if I've told him to him Amica He
he'll confirm it no I'm saying
no no because I know the verses you're
trying to mention and I know where they
come from even in the Quran so I'll take
it which means we created you see which
one of you are going to do your thing
you can go here you can go there but we
know which ones are destined for this
and which ones were Des we know that we
ultimately you're going to go to her no
that's not what it this is bro this is
the I'm telling you okay all right I you
wanted to read the I want to read one
okay let me get it for you again um
so Sai Muslim 27 so there's like three
of them you got you got 2 I usually like
the long version they give usually more
more detail there's a longer version um
let me give you the longer version not
that oh sorry where am I at 27
Oh okay here we go so here's the longer
version if you need the brightness I can
turn it no it's
[Music]
so this this see this
one see there is suspicion about
this no this is what it says you can you
can check for the translation I not
know I don't know
I don't know where the where the doubt
is from no yes dude when he says Abu
said I narrated to Umar D whereupon he
said was it your father who narrated it
to you from Allah's Apostle I said yes
right oh I'm sorry um up here uh uh Abu
Abu said I do not know as to who is in
doubt so yeah that's my whole point you
don't know who's in I don't know where
the doubt is coming from so he asked him
did he come from the word so this is in
Muslim so mostly most of Muslim is
authentic that's what I'm trying to like
explain but yeah I don't hear that so
see the context up to now oh you're
you're looking for
like I'm trying yeah the begin I mean
they just all start like that bro uh
usually they are big ones but they're
they're detailed ones so I will tell you
I will read about it and then maybe
hopefully we can come talk this week
yeah definitely man definitely anyway
thank you man for your time no come here
man it's all right I love the
conversation I love him man I love nice
to meet you too oh you can uh but take
care okay all right oh my God logic
[Music]